so we're going to begin in Sudan with a
24-hour ceasefire has begun between the
Army and part of military rapid support
forces it's the eighth truce since the
conflict started in mid-april United
States and Saudi Arabia brokered the
deal it's meant to allow the safe
delivery of humanitarian aid but
previous ceasefires have failed to stop
much of the fighting we're going to go
live to Heber Morgan she's on in
onderman across the Nile River from
Khartoum are there any signs that this
ceasefire is holding hibber
well we're just four hours into the
start uh we're just three hours into the
start of the ceasefire that began at six
a.m local time or around four uh GMT now
here people say that they were not able
to hear any sounds of gunfire or heavy
artillery that was their biggest fear
and the mediators Saudi Arabia and the
United States says that this is for
humanitarian purpose but it's also for
building a confidence uh confidence
between the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army and they say that they
will be monitoring violations closely
from both sides now the mediators
released a document uh yesterday that
showed the violations from both the
Sudanese Army and the rapid support
forces with regards to the previous
ceasefire both sides have agreed to it
they release statements hours before the
ceasefire came into effect but the rapid
support forces says while they will
abide by the ceasefire they're looking
to the Sudanese Army to do the same and
the Sudanese Army on its part said that
while it will abide by the ceasefire
should the rapid support forces violated
then they will be responding to those
violations and of course in this case
we're talking about military response
and Military violations residents here
are looking to see how this will play
out it's been four hours they say that
if it holds for the next few hours
they'll start making moves some of them
have already started going out of their
homes trying to stock up on basic
Commodities where they can but many
people say that they're quite concerned
to go out they've seen how previous
ceasefires have played out and they're
concerned that in the next few hours
there will be violations from both sides
but one of the the reasons for doing
this particular ceasefire is to bring in
some more humanitarian Aid 24 hours is
not a long time just talk to us about
how badly people particularly say in
Khartoum need that kind of aid
you're talking about people who have
been trapped in the capital for more
than 55 days now many residential areas
do not have running water they do not
have power shops and marketplaces have
either been closed occupied or destroyed
in the fighting between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army
families say that they're running out of
food some of them asking people to try
to donate to them because humanitarian
aid over the past few weeks especially
during the period of ceasefire did not
reach them now humanitarian
organizations say that there is Aid in
the capital Khartoum especially in what
is aidna which is where most of the aid
was delivered to before it was set to
this to be distributed amongst those who
needs it now some people whether it's
here in umdurman or in the southern part
of the capital were able to receive aid
but you're talking about a city that has
a population of more than 8 million
before the conflict began at least one
million have fled at about 7 million
still remaining behind many of them in
desperate situation not having access to
food water then there's the issue of
medical assistance hospitals have been
raided bombed occupied people don't have
access to medical facilities so their
needs are quite huge people say that
they're desperate they're hoping that
some Aid would reach them over the next
few hours over the next 20 hours for
them to be able to get some kind of
respite because they say that if the
ceasefire is not extended then their
situation will get more and more dire
Heather Morgan talking to us from
androman Heber thank you very much
indeed